that's smell what are they mixing these
inks with this must be where the eyeless
get inked I always wanted to join a cult
alright if this is what it takes
don't flinch hey listen time here at
Gamescom 2017 where we just been hands
on with dishonor to death of the
outsider um this is the game that I say
my game is called super great real good
it's more Dishonored an older solid is a
excellent thing so people who don't know
it's a standalone game yeah we thought
was gonna be DLC but it's a full-fledged
standalone experience that it's all
about Billy look from the main dishonor
to you I know her from the boat the boat
and the skiff and the lack of an arm
basically you get to play as Billy and
you have all your powers unlocked from
the outset so she has a bunch of new
ones and you know how like when you play
Dishonored 2 and it just felt so
refreshing having being able to do
mostly the same thing so it was like a
different twist of different spanners if
you played as Emily it's the same
feeling again playing it really so she
has like the movement ability yeah but
instead of like blinking you place a
marker and you can you stop yourself
with the marker yeah I love the effect
that has to like you do the same thing
where if you point out a Ledge or a
surface that you can climb it will give
you the arrows yeah but like if you just
point a normal flat surface it will show
like this outline of her but it's like
in the purple like weird void yeah
exactly and if you place it like in the
air the void like weird silhouette over
there but it's like dripping to the
ground to show that you're gonna fall as
you land that was really cool I love the
small touches in line
presentation that dishonor damn yeah is
real good that that is a super useful
movement ability and it adds a little
more strategy to it so you can't
instantly blink away you've got a double
tap which means you gotta think about
what you're doing before you just try
and commit to you before you commit to
these things and just hope that your
blink will get you out of it there is a
bone time I find a bone charm where you
could quick blink oh really
yeah but instead in terms of like that
more tactical way of moving instead of
just having to be able to see where
you're going
her new like vision ability basically it
kind of pulls you out of Billy's body
and you sort of float around ethereal II
and you can mark enemies like items
notes pickups everything bone charms you
can mark them and also you can drop off
a little after so even if you can't see
where you're meant to be teleporting to
if you move around eventually you can
yeah I think you just need to get into
so usually like you can't teleport or
use your blinks ability through certain
like doors and that kind of stuff or
like you know bars and barred windows
but if you use that like and you can go
through vents and stuff so if you use
that and then place your marker on the
other side and then get within the line
of sight of it you can then teleport
through it in a way that you couldn't
previously or just using that ability on
its own so it's kind of praying like a
symbiosis between the two powers which
is really cool
I don't think I noticed is that you
don't have to pick up elixirs anymore
your mana automatically regenerate at a
very quick rate as well so it really
like
Thompson encourages you like going ham
on these powers and using them to get
around and scope out your surroundings
but my you could have talked to rats you
don't have the heart anymore you can
just like have a chat with a rap it kind
of explains this at the start by telling
you that dad gave Billy I loved his
powers and knowledge and time and that
kind of stuff so she's super powerful
power and I think my favorite of all of
her new powers is the faceless man
ability reference that Game of Thrones
she can basically if she grabs someone
kind of their hands up and it's really
cool like rocky effect yes a christ-like
the same it looks like the same effect
they use for the mesmerized thing where
the obelisk appears that kind of
material but it creates this face in a
hand just to show that you've got that
power active and it replicates the
unconscious person's physic so everyone
else will see you as that person they
have to be unconscious you can't kill
them or do anything crazy like that you
can only do it to one person one yeah so
I couldn't just keep going back and
using the same body and over and over
again but as you're walking around the
other people sort of look you in the eye
and behave as if you are the person
whose face you are wearing and it's
super useful because a lot of the times
I find it when I'm in Dishonored is I'm
like out of people's eye side I'm not
really on the ground much of us I have
to dip in and kill someone but this time
it means
explore like a whole new level yeah of
the game yes you limited somewhat by the
your mana pool but it's like you said
you recover it really quickly and it
only dreams when you're actually moving
so if you're just standing stationary
it's not training it so you can like use
it to like very strategically edge your
way around a tricky scenario but it's
really really cool I love the the way
these powers kind of come together to
create this like new it is encouraging
you to try and approach different
puzzles and different scenarios in a
variety of ways and I think they've been
really smart in the way they kind of
lead you down those possible the enemy
placement was really tricky at times
yeah and like that that kind of forced
me to think about how can I use these
powers to get around this and it wasn't
the most creative way because I had like
an hour to try and get stuff done but I
can see people really coming up with
some really cool like speedruns now a
video it's gonna be really really cool
but I mean story-wise obviously you
didn't get to see that much of it and to
be honest until i play the full thing i
don't want to know that much of it but
you're basically you're playing is billy
stout is the wrong way he's in a rough
way he's old you know he's got rooms
that aren't healing anymore he's full of
regret but the two of you can have come
together and decide that the outsider
has to die because he is the cause of
pretty much all the upset in the world
right now the boy trouble and yeah and
apparently there's a knife that can kill
a god a Valyrian steel is Valyrian steel
so Billy's gonna find the knife and try
and kill the outside are hoping that
God's condition improves but also it's
sort of like you're in Karnak or again
it's just as beautiful as it wasn't
Dishonored 2 but you kind of seen like
new areas of it which is really
you're not dealing with the howlers and
the overseers there's a new gang in town
the islets yep
which is kind of more like a cult which
is seem that good to make love a good
cause have a good cult but it's
basically it's just it's just it's real
good like we could keep could keep
talking about like there's great puzzles
in there like the hour we play be like
the environmental storytelling is really
strong and just super exciting and I
mean the music as well but everyone
looks great it's a great game it's
coming out right yeah but for more from
this year's games come to make sure you
keep your eyes peeled to games what I
call more what's new cheetah fun slash
the games fun by play this on it too
and define different in addition yeah
it's great